c'est à la résidence les moissonneurs
logements pour personnes âgées qu'eux se
sont rendus ce mardi 10 novembre dans la
matinée le responsable du service
coursier ainsi que deux agents pour
chercher la liste des courses d'une
habitante
on n'a pas beaucoup de 2 to le choc on
vend salat pain fromage des aliments de
première nécessité pour cette dame
atteint d'une pathologie
j'ai plus de 65 ans j'ai 66 ans et je
souffre d'une pathologie chronique dont
youtube est fragile j'ai fait partie de
la population phrase l'île et ce système
de courtrai est formidable pour moi le
tambour de confinement une fois la liste
donnée les coursiers parts au
supermarché du coin avec le bon de
commande qui permet d'avancer les frais
ce dispositif avait été un succès lors
du confinement
avec plus de 15 demandes par jour on
descend à 6,7 la personne qu'ils
appellent par jour d'eau alors on va
voir avec le temps pour penser peut-être
que ça va ça va peut-être monte en
puissance dans l'est dans les jours qui
viennent ces services est disponible du
lundi au vendredi sur rendez-vous de
8h30 à 12h15 et de 13h30 à 17h30
c'est une manière d'être solidaire de
participer à ce moment qu'elle est très
très compliqué hein pour tout le monde
et on sait bien que ces personnages sont
très vulnérables
il ya aussi biseau lmnp quelque part
donc nous aussi ça permet de faire dieu
te créer ce lien avec ces personnes qui
sont à l'extérieur
ce dispositif de coursiers maintenu
jusqu'au 1er décembre et pourrait être
prolongé si le confinement l'était
également